CLARK TUCKER WON THE NOMINATION
FOR HOUSING.
HE WILL FACE REPUBLICAN
INCUMBENT.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, WERE GOING
TO FOCUS ON THE POLITICS IN THE
NATION'S MOST POPULOUS STATE.
IN A MOMENT, I WILL TALK WITH
CALIFORNIA REPUBLICAN
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE JOHN COX
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE JOHN CO
COX.
FIRST, WHY THE TOP DEMOCRAT MAY
SUPPORT THE TOP REPUBLICAN.
>> IT TAKES COURAGE TO MAKE REAL
CHANGE.
THAT IS GAVIN NEWSOM.
>> LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM HOLDS A COMFORTABLE LEAD
IN THE GUBERNATORIAL RACE GOING
INTO THE JUNE 5 PRIMARY.
WHICH ON THE CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
WILL SEND THE TOP TWO VOTE
GETTERS INTO NOVEMBERS RUNOFF
REGARDLESS OF PARTY AFFILIATION.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA CALLED HIM
ONE OF AMERICA'S FINEST MAYORS.
>> THE RACE FOR THE SECOND SPOT
APPEARS TO BE BETWEEN FORMER
L.A. MAYOR ANTONIO VILLARAIGOSA,
WHOSE BACKERS KNOW AN
ASSOCIATION WITH OBAMA WILL PLAY
WELL WITH DEMOCRATS.
AND REPUBLICAN JOHN COX, A
SAN DIEGO BUSINESSMAN WHO
PRESIDENT TRUMP RECENTLY
ENDORSED VIA A TWEET SAYING
"JOHN COX IS THE MAN.
HE WILL BE THE BEST GOVERNOR
YOU'VE EVER HAD."
THE LATEST POLL HAS VILLARAIGOSA
AND COX IN A STATISTICAL DEAD
HEAT WITH NEWSOM COMFORTABLY HAD
HEAT WITH NEWSOM COMFORTABLY HA
HAD.
>> TAKING THOUSANDS IN ILLEGAL
GIFTS FROM SPECIAL INTERESTS.
>> IF HIS ADS ARE ANYTHING TO GO
BY, ATTACKING VILLARAIGOSA WHILE
BY, ATTACKING VILLARAIGOSA WHIL
BY, ATTACKING VILLARAIGOSA WHIL.
NEWSOM WOULD SEEM TO PREFER TO
FACE A CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICAN
AND THEN A FELLOW.
THE VILLARAIGOSA CAMPAIGN
DESCRIBES NEWSOM'S APPROACH AS
CYNICAL AND SAYS HE WILL "DO
JUST ABOUT ANYTHING TO GET
ELECTED, INCLUDING SELLING OUT
HIS OWN DEMOCRATIC PARTY."
FOR NEWSOM, THE CALCULATION
SEEMS FAIRLY SIMPLE.
DEFEATING A REPUBLICAN IN THE
GENERAL ELECTION HERE IN WHAT IS
LARGELY LIBERAL CALIFORNIA WILL
BE EASIER THAN TAKING ON ANOTHER